[Music]
what are you waiting for
Dusty are you okay in the big door prize
we find Dusty with his family on the
occasion of his 40th birthday
somebody who thinks that he has
everything he wants one day his machine
arrives
promises to tell people their life
potential and from Dusty the machine
opens up a Chasm of non-certainty as he
reevaluates whether he might actually
want something more out of life where'd
you get it no idea just appeared like
magic is that right
oh
it's also about an entire town going
through a midlife crisis this machine
turns everyone's life upside down like a
dancer Superstar male model Make It Stop
some people get excited some people have
questions we're actually getting a
divorce the Morpho inspired us what it's
so fun to watch the different ways
people interpret their potential I got
Explorer which obviously means sexual
Explorer obviously even in place where
people think they know everything about
everyone are you flexing to my relaxed
arms when did you get so jacked out
everyone has their own secret everyone
has their own inner struggle feeling
that's just like a big heavy foot in
your chest I think that's just anxiety
Mr Hubbard I get that a lot
I think what makes the big door prize
original is this incredible cast of
characters this is so different from
anything that I've worked on
wow he's cool
kind of like this Fantastical bunny but
also a really heartbreaking show you can
let me go now
exciting time to talk about Big Ideas
and this is a fantastic comedy with a
great premise what I hope with people
when they watch is that they see
themselves in some of these characters
it really touches on these Universal
longings within all of us and in funny
and poignant way if you were offered
another life potential would you take it
[Music]
thank you